hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast adaptive process design
automation and analytics in laboratory
R&D presented by Tim Gardner I'm Suzy
Valdez of lab rich and I will be your
moderator for today's event we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this presentation is interactive we want
to hear from you to questions comments
and even answers can be submitted via
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of your screen we'll try to get to
everyone but if not we will make sure to
follow up with you by email you can also
alert large the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of your slide window if you
cannot hear or see this presentation
properly but it's know by clicking on
the support button at the top right or
the Q&A button at the lower left I will
now turn the presentation over to our
fabulous presenter Tim Gardner welcome
Tim thank you thank you the opportunity
to present today I'm looking forward to
telling you about rhythm and how we're
addressing some of the most difficult
problems in scientific experimentation
and data analytics in modern argue
laboratories riffin is a three year old
company based in Oakland California and
we offer a cloud-based platform for a
collaborative process design and
integrative data analytics of scientific
experiments and Ardie organizations our
roots are actually in the rd of
industrial buy offices from DNA
engineering and strain engineering and
cell line development all the way
through scale-up and tech transfer of
these technologies to full-scale
manufacturing and those roots have
translated into an architecture for
riffin capabilities that we hope really
resonates with scientists in the lab and
data scientists as well an analyst of in
charge of new product development for
industrial sectors in the food and the
biopharmaceutical in the biotech and the
materials and chemical industries so let
me begin with an outline of some of the
pain points that we have heard from the
marketplace from people in the
laboratory and how we've distilled them
into sort of a slightly humorous view of
the world as it is now first of all we
hear the people are frustrated with
electronic lab notebooks or as we
summarized it electronic milk lab
notebooks are where your data goes to
die we also hear about limbs and
frustrations with limbs or as we like to
say limbs solving yesterday's problem
tomorrow or the day after and
spreadsheets the worst data man solution
management solution ever except for all
the others what this summarizes - for
many people is a sort of resignation
that a data solution for Rd will always
be suboptimal and will never quite rise
to solving the kinds of analytical and
hypothesis analytical challenges that
they want to apply to resolve hypotheses
riffin doesn't believe it has to be the
case and to get to a solution we looked
across many different fields of human
endeavor and realized something
fundamental that every field of human
ingenuity begins with a blueprint
architectural diagrams for building
storyboards for filmmaking
computer-aided design files for
automobiles and airplanes basically
everything you do in human engineering
it starts this way except for science in
science because of its perhaps empirical
roots people just go out into the lab
they sketch out an experimental designer
to go out in the lab and do it and they
collect data and then attempt to
interpret that data oftentimes that day
is collected in notebooks spreadsheets
databases many different
flavors of data depending on how you
collected it that then become an
unmanageable problem thereafter to try
to synthesize and we surveyed many
dozens of companies in the marketplace
over the years
and heard common themes of frustration
such as our data is all over the place
and our result end in the data graveyard
we can't determine which variables
matter or which results are real and we
work on what we know not what matters we
can't control our process variation
these distill down to three critical
issues spreadsheet hell as we like to
say
unlink able data set and unrecorded
methods these are the core issues that
riffin is resolving with its design and
analysis platform these problems to put
it into the framework of scientific
experimentation and hypothesis testing
boils down to a clouding of the
fundamental relationship that we're
trying to resolve in any kind of
scientific experiment which is basically
if you really symptom rise it is does
variable X affective variable Z that
could be a process variable affecting a
critical quality parameter that could be
a perturbation to a biological system
affecting some outcome or physiological
trait
whatever it is we're trying to find
these correlations in an ideal world
these correlations look like this
perfectly lined up one variable
affecting the other but the reality is
that with all of our errors and
measurement issues those relationships
are much less clear the same data with
noise looks like this the relationship
perhaps still being there but harder to
detect because of the noise or even
worse if you've underpowered those
experiments because you haven't set up a
proper experimental design with
sufficient statistical power or because
the data you've collected from different
experiments are not combined about
because of various day to day or week to
week issues and measurement or inability
to integrate data sets you don't have
the power to detect
relationship at all or in the worst case
scenario the data are stored in
different databases and systems without
the joining and linking information to
ask the question if two variables are
correlated these problems are endemic
throughout the different fields of
science and they're very similar no
matter what field or what aspect of the
product lifecycle your work on but the
good news is that we've seen this
problem before and we've also seen its
solution looking back to your history we
see that in automobile manufacturing in
many fields of manufacturing they went
to a revolution from the 1960s to the
1980s or at least some companies did and
that revolution was the implementation
of total quality practices when Japanese
auto manufacturers adopted an implement
in these practices they saw their
productivity in production of vehicles
triple or even quadruple over a 20-year
period while companies that didn't apply
them GM Ford and Chrysler saw no
improvement in productivity what this
boils down to is a realization that if
every other car you produce is the lemon
or defective in some way and you have to
throw it out then half of your
industrial capacity is going to waste
when you get quality it's not just about
making customers happy which is
obviously a good outcome it's about not
wasting resources on unproductive
endpoints and in the scientific world we
don't necessarily realize this but we're
experiencing the same kind of waste
because many many many of our
experiments are devoted to unproductive
alcohol questions that don't resolve
because there's too much noise or time
spent on artifacts that turn out to be
false we apply sometimes euphemistic
labels to that call it regression to the
mean but that's nothing more than
chasing an artifact that was a
consequence of noise that once noise
dissipates you see wasn't real in the
first place so a bottom line if we can
take these lessons from manufacturing
which are now ubiquitous in the
manufacturing world and translate them
through an Rd sector we can actually see
a
matic improvement in productivity
meaning the pace with which we discover
new information and build on it and this
is an example of exactly that kind of
productivity benefit in my own
experiences in a company developing
engineered yeast the yeast were
developed over a multi-year period they
were genetically engineered to produce a
compound at high yields and the goal of
this project was to improve those yields
through genetic engineering in the early
years due to a lot of noise in the
system we would see rare large jumps in
performance with a lot of plateaus and
flat lining in between and at some point
along the way we started to get
concerned that we would never emerge
from from those flatline and we
introduced a quality program which
reduced the error measurement by six
fold what that did is make the lots of
little improvements that normally would
go undetected because they were below
the noise threshold it made those
improvements detectable and reproducible
and when you can find those improvements
and then build on them quickly you've
got an overall doubling in the pace of
discovery and development of those
strengths then the key to that is being
able to not only just detect those
results but trust them and to stack that
knowledge quickly and that's a metaphor
for science as a whole which is now a
global enterprise across many dozens of
people collaborating on the typical
product project or thousands of people
collaborating on industrial development
programs you need to share and build on
each other's work so what are these
lessons of manufacturing quality that
have been successfully also applied in a
biotech setting and how can they be
applied more broadly that's really the
foundation of what we're if in saw to
address and to embed until its top or
capabilities they're actually quite
simple and they're quite well known they
start with design the idea that if you
want to have a trustworthy result you
have to be very explicit
about how are you going to deliver that
result was the process or technology or
method you're going to use to achieve
that outcome then you measure whether
you're actually delivering on the design
specification and analyze that data to
look for deviations from expectation and
ways to improve it once you make those
improvements you share the result and
iterate cycling back to the design to
improve on the design and it's a
continuous process it's often called
continuous improvement but what that
really means is design your system
measure its performance analyze it for
improvement opportunities and then
update your organization to work better
the problem is that these methods which
are commonly applied in manufacturing
are often hard to apply an RD because
aren't econ stantly changing it's so
flexible there's so many different data
modality hard to bring that together
so what riffin is done is created a
cloud-based collaborative software
platform that embeds these principles
into its architecture and it's
completely adaptive meaning as you
change your experimental research
processes on it on an hourly basis even
the entire system updates itself and
adapts to those changes so that you can
continue to collect data and apply the
principles of cloud in essence it starts
with it boils down to those four phases
a design capability which allows you to
specify without ambiguity the
experimental methods and processes you
use it then uses those experimental
processes to provide automated context
to your data as you require it in
real-time that allows you to endow your
data with communion without having to
write down a lot of information for
typically that data is then linked
together using again the process design
is the guide for how to join data sets
together so that the whole analytical
pipeline or what in many organizations
is called an ETL layer or extract
transform layer is automated and the
outcome is a
data table that's fully structured and
ready for statistical analysis with just
a click of the button and finally all of
this is built into a real-time
collaborative sharing platform akin to
Google Docs where anything you do in
your web browser riffin is instantly
reflected to anybody else's browser
who's looking at that same information
so when you apply these principles the
way that riffin has developed you start
with an environment of data collection
and experiment that looks a lot like
this manual back records and a
spreadsheet for collecting data spread
out across experiments and people in
different modality and transforming it
to this which is riffin providing a
graphical view of experimental processes
with full sample tracking collection of
all specifications settings parameter
settings and actual data into one place
organized so that with just a couple
clicks you can get to correlative
analytics as shown in the bottom to
understand the relationship between
properties of your process and your
biological or chemical system and how
they affect outcomes in your product or
your physiological traits and now we're
going to walk you briefly through the
different aspects of riffin in a little
bit more detail as mentioned before it's
this four part design measure analyze
and share cycle and we start with
outlining how written works in the
design so this is a view of HPLC process
defined and written with each of these
boxes being a step or group of steps in
the execution of your HPLC method
everything from equilibrate example
injection to analysis and the left side
of each box is the inputs to that step
in it right side is the output so riffin
organizes experiments into a series of
link input-output transformations where
the links between them
the materials and equipment flowing from
step to step down in the bottom you see
the explicit definition of those
equipment and material all of which come
from a control vocabulary which I'll
show in a little bit including their
specifications and units which can be
used to augment and and provide the
metadata to understand the data that's
actually collected everything in riffin
is version controlled like source code
and branch able and you can use those
different versions to execute
experiments each version still being a
live and executable version so you can
have multiple experiments on different
versions of your process and you can
augment with video and pictures and text
and Facebook like seeds of comments as
you develop the process each process in
design mode becomes a template for
execution of experiments and when you
execute those experiments you're going
to collect data from the laboratory so
riffin provides a facility to collect
data from very any modality that you
would get in a lab from manual data
collection and batch records that you
might typically keep in logbooks
by hand to acquiring data from databases
lymph system vo n data historian or
parsing directly the instruments offer
the instrument files the software data
files that come out of instruments all
of this is collected parsed and sent
through an encrypted channels to the
riffin cloud where the different data
streams in a different variables in
those data files are attached to the
process design to each property in the
process and contextualize on the fly so
that you know what that data mean as
soon as it's collected the raw data
files are also archived and then all
that data can be accessed through riffin
or through programmatic means including
a restful Web API CSV exports which are
ready for analysis in R or Spotfire or
jump or any common analytical program or
screaming into data light
each file that comes out no matter what
experiment that was used that was
collecting the data comes out in the
same generic structure when you're
designing these processes for
experimentation riff and harness is a
controlled vocabulary to ensure that
terminology is consistent from
experiment to experiment from process to
process from group to group and team to
team and what that does is not only make
it easier interpret what what's
happening it also ensures that the data
is my Nobel so that when you're
correlating categories of information
with other variables in your system you
don't have to deal with 20 different
versions of a name for the very same
material or equipment this controlled
vocabulary includes about 80 thousand
terms and it's dynamically customizable
as you can see at the bottom of that
autocomplete list you can add new terms
you can reorganize them in addition to
controlled vocabularies riffin provides
sample and inventory registration and
assignment of those materials to
experiments in this view you're seeing a
listing of different animals that are in
this organization's inventory and the
properties of those animals listed in
the upper right pane including the last
reported values such as the math of that
animal in a previous experiment when you
want to use an animal or piece of
equipment or a sample you can directly
and assign it to the experimental run or
experimental sample or the experimental
execution instance for that process so
what you see in the bottom is a list of
six different runs each of which is
using a different animal whether it's
diabetic or not and the identity of the
animal assigned and all of its
properties so you don't have to re-enter
all this information because it's taken
from the inventory system even more
importantly riffin tracks the
propagation of samples and inventory
equipment from step to step across your
process so as you are for
sample here going from the formulation
of a treatment and the formulation step
to the injection of those treatments the
solutions into these animals Riven is
tracking the different animals that are
being treated in the second step step
for the dosing and feeding and the
source of the material and the pre
retire step which is the formulation
step and you can simply select a sample
in any step and see what its parent or
child what this tracking of samples in a
direct way facilitates the analytical
capability because riff is analytics
engine and track traces all of those
parent-child relationships across
equipment and material flow and is able
to connect and link the data that you
collect on one step or one sample with
the data in its downstream steps
downstream samples what that allows you
to do is is using the combination of the
specifications that are provided from
the design and this traceability
identify when things are out of control
or abnormal and then instantly identify
root causes by looking upstream at the
materials that are flowing into a step
and what might be driving the expected
or unexpected variation this could be a
good thing in the sense that you are
perturbing your system intentionally and
looking to see what perturbations of
drive variation and deviation or if we a
bad thing because you're trying to
deliver quality and you don't want
deviation in either case you can harness
the power statistical multivariate
analysis to answer these questions and
then riffin is also providing
visualization capabilities as
illustrated here which allows you to
take a look at all of your sample and
then filter them dynamically to
understand whether the samples are
exceeding some threshold for example for
propagation to the next stage of your of
your experiment so if you're doing cell
line development you want to find your
best hits and then you want to select
those identify them and tag them you can
do that and then
propagate those tag back to the
experiment so that you can so that you
can move those samples forward to the
next stage all of this as I mentioned is
provided in a real-time collaborative
framework so every process every
experiment every sample is shareable
through an interface akin to as I said
Google Docs with Dropbox or box where
you can simply type in the email address
of your collaborator set their
administrative level they could be an
administrator a designer an operator or
a viewer and control whether they're
allowed to share this information with
other people and then once you've done
that that this process and all of the
experiments and data you've collected
all of the versions of it are accessible
by that collaborator and if you give
them the permissions they're also
allowed to edit and improve on that
process
so in summary listen has been designed
to synthesize all the elements that are
commonly required to complete successful
and and data-driven experimental
processes in a lab it resolved the data
structuring and contextualization
problem otherwise known as spreadsheet
help and it does that in a flexible
dynamic way that allows you to design
processes and modify them on a slide but
still continue to collect and structure
data it allows you to automate the data
integration across every kind of
instrument from HPLC to hand and collect
data to spectroscope photometers plate
reader file limb systems historian and
automatically join all of that
information into a statistical data
table for analysis and it provides the
ability to continuously evolve and
update your work to the version control
system which facilitates the product
lifecycle as the processes go from early
stage discovery all the way towards
clinical trials and manufacturing that
history and record of its evolutions
becomes
and parent and of course it's shareable
so you can easily transfer information
between collaborating groups which tends
helps to resolve the ambiguity typically
endemic to tension tech transfer riffin
really seize this opportunity there is
an opportunity in process based research
in life sciences and chemistry to adopt
some of the practices that we see in
discrete industries namely the idea of
cos of continuous improvement and rapid
prototyping in a discrete world you can
create a computer a design file send it
off to a manufacturing facility for
prototyping and a very short period of
time and then iterate and we see an
opportunity to do the same thing in
process based industries using the
digital medium of process design and
capabilities of the cloud to facilitate
this idea of rapid prototyping and
continuous improvement and for that you
need a two-way sharing of manufacturing
data and RD data between the two sides
of the product lifecycle riffin is there
to support all of these for example and
biologics development from discovery
research to cell line and process
development process transfer and Quality
Assurance all of the are nearly all of
the needs of those different aspects of
the product lifecycle are accessible
through written and so to conclude all
we do with one final thought about data
integration and data silos which I think
is perfectly captured in this this is
cartoon and I will conclude my remarks
and happy to take any questions thank
you so much for that wonderful
presentation Tim we want to get right to
the questions and input so here's a
reminder as to how audience members can
communicate with us questions can be
submitted via the Q&A button at the
lower left if we are unable to get to
your questions due to a time constraint
Tim will get go ahead and reach out to
you via
email so let's take our first question
it looks like an audience member would
like to know is riffin and ELN or al IMS
a limb system really both and neither
al lens and limb systems are sort of the
traditional technology for what people
like to say managing laboratory data we
really try to avoid the word manage and
riffin altogether because manage
managing data speaks of putting it to
death tucking it away in a corner so
you're not bothered by it the whole
point of data is to put it to work and
riffin is architected to deliver
analytical capability and to do all the
things you need with experimental design
and data organization and structuring to
facilitate analytics so riffin can work
with the lymph system we can pull data
from limb systems in real time we can
pull data from the LM system we can push
data to those systems so if you wanted
to continue to use those systems in your
laboratory that would be fine and we can
still deliver the analytical value on
top of that but at the same time if you
wanted to dispense with those systems
because riffin is both flexible like an
e ln and structured like a Lim's we can
actually become a primary data
collection system as well so you can use
it in a hybrid mode where some parts of
your organization are using written kind
of like a limp and others are using it
as as an analytical engine or even one
experiment could have elements of both
great I think you actually answered this
next audience question which it was do I
have to then get rid of my ln or limb
system to use riffin yes right yeah I
just do not and we can work in harmony
with existing systems or or provide them
if you don't have any engine
can riffin connect to instrument yes we
the primary mechanism for connecting an
instrument data there's a couple one is
a lot of instruments produce flat file
as output but those flat files need to
be interpreted and riffin provides a
mechanism to parse instrument data file
and place the parse data into rhythm so
that parsing capability is entirely
configurable on-the-fly by scientists
and savable to the processes the other
mechanism is a data agent which
facilitates direct real-time
connectivity to databases and
instruments it has a plug-in
architecture
so certainly riffin is a young company
we don't have the driver for every
instrument out there but should your
organization want a direct connection
it's possible to create a driver that
provides it or to ingest data through
flat files or through databases
connections and we do provide
out-of-the-box connections for databases
there is also a RESTful API which allows
you to push and pull read and write data
to and from riffin directly to the core
data model so any of those routes become
a means by which you can integrate with
those instruments wonderful we've a lot
of great questions coming in something
very similar an audience member would
like to know can I use our Python SAS
JMP tableau Spotfire other analytical
packages with riffin yeah riffin is
designed under the assumption that no
matter how much we build and do it there
will always be analyses that you want to
do that riffin doesn't do and the last
thing we ever want to do is to lock your
data up so we provide every mechanism we
possibly can for you to get your data
out in a statistical and data mining
form as easily as possible and what that
means is you can have direct queries and
connection from our jump spot for any of
those systems can pull data out
we from riffin ready for analysis and
immediately visualized it or you could
stream it in the analytical pipeline or
as I mentioned data links which we're
doing for some customers and Tim will
within support inventory and sample
tracking yes as I mentioned earlier
riffin does provide sample registration
of biologic material chemical material
it also types those so that you know
that a compound is a different physical
entity than a piece of equipment so we
have a ontology of over 80,000 different
material and equipment and chemical
types built in which as I mentioned is
extensible so not only do we register
samples and biological entities and
chemical entities and equipment but we
also we also type them and we also keep
track of all the recorded data that is
associated with those entities awesome
thank you and I think that answers this
next question which was what if my
process keeps changing do I leave that
past data
well yeah slightly different question um
so as I mentioned Griffin has version
control and as you improve your
processes and change them all of the
past experiments that were run on past
versions remain associated with those
past versions yet when you export your
data it will compile all the data and
all of the parameters and all of the
variants of your processes and your
experimental results into a single
contiguous data file so you can then ask
questions of correlation when I change
this parameter how did that impact the
outcomes that I saw and you can ask that
question across months and months of
data even as the process changes great
we have so many great questions you have
a couple more minutes to answer a few
more what sort of research can riffin
support
well-written design bits or process
based industries those very broadly
anything that is recipe driven meaning
you have material inputs you apply some
transformation heat or pressure or
biological reaction enzyme treatments
fermentations just simply movement any
transformation of those inputs to
physical output or even non physical
inputs and output is audible within a
reference process designer so we have
currently are supporting customers in
food industries in biopharmaceutical
process development cell line
development analytical chemistry
industrial biotechnology enzyme
development fermentation processes all
of those processes are currently
represented and supported and written it
at our customers and and even animal
studies we have processes for animal
studies that we have developed thank you
we have time for one more an audience
member would like to know how secure is
riffin Rifton is the very first thing we
asked when we started building riffin is
how to makes it as secure as we possibly
can with the most cutting-edge
technologies why because we realize that
research and development data is the
most precious asset for innovation
driven organizations and so we begin
with confidentiality any data that
riffin hold is under a signed
confidentiality agreement between riffin
and that company or that that customer
so that there's no sharing of data with
any third party by legal obligation
secondly we even even implemented the
latest and most cutting-edge security
encryption technologies we have
end-to-end encryption of all data at
rest from the database to the inter
process communication within the cloud
all the way to the customer endpoint
browser or data file it's fully
encrypted
it uses 20 2014 that is encryption
technology in addition we have 14x
redundancy on our data backups meaning
there's first three times with real-time
failover protection on your data it's
copied to a fourth real-time backup that
backup is snapshot at every six hours
and reflected across five continents in
ten copies so that there's really no
possibility of losing your data due to a
disaster
and finally we adopt the most the best
practices in the security industry from
penetration testing 200 watts
programming standards to other
international standards for coding and
software development lifecycle and cloud
based security Tim Gardner thank you so
much for your very informative
presentation do you have any final
comments for the audience no I just
appreciate the opportunity to share of
ism thank you so much I'd also like to
take the opportunity to thank lab roots
for making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand until August
2017 keep an eye out for an email from
laboratory me when this webcast will be
available for replay we encourage you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thanks again for joining us
and we hope to see you again next time
goodbye